[Musik]
auf und davon
mit der mobiliar versicherungen und
vorsorge ein hof am see silvia und
marcus burg suchen die ruhe ihn schwer
sie wollen dort ferienwohnungen
vermieten wie warme corp stefano lotti
und stefano navarrete zieht es in die
karibik im land ist der kita vital sie
ihre chance und familie zogaj möchte
sich in südafrika neu erfinden
ihr traum eine eigene lodz
[Musik]
es wirkt ganzen kommen
der hausrat aus dem thurgau hocker ist
sind vor fünf wochen nach südafrika
aufgebrochen
die letzten meter für den riesigen hoch
seecontainer er ist voller zügel kisten
75 kubikmeter das gesamte hab und gut
der familie die heimat beginnt auf
finnisch nahezu rundum aber alles
verdrängt in der letzten folge kann
familie zogaj nicht mehr voran
alles nach plan laufe ihr traum von der
gästefarm ist geplatzt
ohne eine gute idee können sie hier
nicht bleiben
das konzept ist nach wie vor ort aus
stefano navarra übernahm in mexiko
erstmalig geschäfte seines onkels die
auswanderer bezogen ihre eigenen
wohnungen alles war für sie eingerichtet
in schweden sind markus und sylvia bord
nun auf sich allein gestellt ihr erstes
projekt zwei ferienwohnungen auf ihrem
hof herrichten
ich sage der und liefert der
kontrastfarbe ist du dir vorstellen
[Musik]
in südafrika ist es endlich soweit war
sei aus sicherheits plombe ist weg nach
9000 kilometern
[Gelächter]
das meiste haben die tokens mitgenommen
aus ihrem haus am bodensee ins neue
leben von hier alles auspacken und sich
einrichten geht aber noch nicht die
villa in stanford haben türkei es
vorerst für zwei monate gemietet es ist
wichtig dass man das auto prallte tja
wenn es passiert dass für dichte bewegt
wird die eintrachtler anders acht landet
wenn sie suchen sondern für den planet
an das land das ich wäre ja fast 17.000
franken ließen sie sich den umzug bis
jetzt schon kosten
das meine ich keine räumlichkeiten sind
jetzt sehr groß sehr ansteckend deshalb
sehe ich jetzt alles ein davoser
schlitten beweislast die grünen haben
der mit klar wenn man dann ihr werdet
aber trotzdem dusty davoser schlitten
das ist ein größter star jay ist im
alten bikes 12 genau
ja das hochschalten nach zweieinhalb
stunden sind die schätze wieder verstand
und bis auf weiteres eingelagert von
ihren ursprünglichen plänen für das neue
leben sind die türkei noch weit entfernt
[Musik]
playa del carmen expandierender
ferienort in der karibik
stefano navarra und mitarbeiterin lässt
sie besuchen kunden von stefanos onkel
[Musik]
nächsten zeigt ihm wie das geschäft
läuft in jeder monat wäre die container
ist wirklich eine spezialität der laden
laden wo motto beliefern
eine neue bestellung die delikatessen öl
pasta wein kommen direkt aus italien
stefano will das geschäft weiter
ausbauen
[Musik]
mein leben als account manager in dieses
geschäft des onkels muss sich stefano
erst einleben
der 31 jährige hatte im baselbiet
zusammen mit seinem geschäftspartner
eine personalagentur und vermittelte
handwerker auf baustellen
[Musik]
die paste aus italien muss durch den
zoll mit sechs jungen und
einfühlungsvermögen
also habe ich mir mit dem befasst sich
jetzt schon mal und sie macht sehr gut
sehr klar dass man wirklich gut langsam
und ich verstand alles ein neues
geschäftsfeld stefano erobertes schritt
für schritt in der casa italia hat der
andere stefano den kopf ganz woanders
die beiden besitzen in der schweiz immer
noch ein zweifamilienhaus für das sie
bis jetzt keinen käufer gefunden haben
nun haben sich endlich zwei
interessenten gemeldet
[Musik]
gut möglich dass er bald zurück muss um
den hausverkauf abzuschließen
[Musik]
der plan genommen
endlich feierabend der neue job strengt
an kundenbesuchen formulare für den zoll
ausfüllen lagerbestände kontrollieren
mit leslie und das alles auf spanisch im
krankendienst musste
[Musik]
zehn hektar umschwung gehören zu burghof
am see so viel wie 14 fußballfelder
markus ist gelernter schreiner zusammen
mit seiner frau verdiente er nicht
schlecht
sie verkaufte zuletzt als beraterin
holzhäuser aber so ein großes anwesen
hätten sie sich in der alten heimat nie
leisten können
ich glaube es gibt wenige geschütze
auffahren und wenn dann hat man keinen
günstigen vw bus sondern was für mich
ein großer benzel und es war ein traktor
die zwei zimmer in diesem häuschen
wollen die boots an feriengäste
vermieten
sie werben dafür bereits in einer
schweizer lokalzeitung und im internet
wegen der schwangerschaft übernimmt sie
wieder leichtere arbeiten sie gestaltet
die wohnungen und sucht die möbel aus
andere soldaten fertig ist
danke dass ihr hof am see wurde 1907
gebaut und nach und nach erweitert die
beiden wollen den ursprünglichen
charakter bewahren
[Musik]
sevilla ist im siebten monat schwere
lasten sind für sie tabu
mccafé
[Musik]
16 jaime melo ist apple hat es steht
alles drin was energie hat schlecht
geschlafen
heute fängt für sie und ihren bruder die
schule an der niko anders
ja ich würde mich
märz ab
[Musik]
20 minuten brauchen die türkei bis zur
schule
sie legt ihn herr manisch einem
touristenort bekannt für das whale
watching
[Musik]
die celebrations cool ist eine
privatschule mit international
anerkanntem abschluss für ihre kinder
bezahlen die talk rund 500 franken pro
monat nur wenige südafrikanische
familien können sich das leisten
mikas erste schulstunde lauter neue
schreiben rechnen englisch lernen wenig
geschockt
[Musik]
der siebenjährige mieter schlägt sich
tapfer in der schulstube nebenan kämpft
seine schwester annika
[Musik]
als neuer in der klasse soll sie ein
paar aufgaben lösen
die lehrerin will herausfinden was sie
schon kann
[Musik]
momentan ist schritt für schritt
kreispokal tores bleibt in der nähe
erster schultag in südafrika ein test
auch für sie
[Musik]
stefano navarrete ist inzwischen schon
sechs wochen allein in mexiko und regelt
die immobiliengeschäfte
sie akzeptieren domingo wenn die synchro
ja dieser band noch der falter soll
flugs respekt vor der weltpresse motor
racing groß applikation
stefano hat die baustelle fast jeden tag
kontrolliert seit sein kollege in der
schweiz ist er hat klimaanlagen besorgt
matratzen organisiert die bäder
eingerichtet und liebe spielten ohne
dich ja schon montiert
stefano hat den bau zügig vorangetrieben
mit seinem bauleiter andrea ohne hilfe
von onkel fernando
ich bin vor ihm nur das ist froh
draufhat ganzer bewilligung schichten
haben sowieso verschiedenen schweizer
qualität gewachsen
die appartements sind die erste
investition der auswanderer in einer
immobilie in mexiko
liestal im baselbiet stefano lotte ist
nun schon seit sechs wochen hier und
sucht einen käufer für ihr haus
ja es hätte schon mexiko traf ich
natürlich da aber bevor das erwartet man
sehen ob man das auch ein urteil das
nicht vielfältig wochen in ihrer alten
firma war stefano für buchhaltung und
technik zuständig die rolle als
verkäufer ist neu für ihn
bisher machte dass der andere stefano
das zweifamilienhaus war teil ihrer
alten firma hier haben sie etliche
leiharbeiter untergebracht seit einem
halben jahr steht es leer
ob jetzt der neue versuch war ein makler
soll schwung in den verkauf bringen und
stefano klappert noch einmal den
bekanntenkreis ab zeit wenn jemand das
album und firmiert das wetter es ist 25
walter blöd aber wohl wenig kapital
durch große investition sowohl das
verlängere war so meine hoch kommen die
touristen oder gar stefano ist sicher in
mexiko könnten sie mit dem geld aus dem
hausverkauf noch viel mehr profit machen
[Musik]
in schweden steht die erste
schwangerschaft untersuchung an
der geburtstermin rückt näher
in der frauenklinik in wimmer will
silvia einen termin mit der hebamme
vereinbaren sie wir und markus haben
einen stehtisch grundkurs besucht und
ein paar privat lektionen genommen
vollständig
[Musik]
der reform zugestimmt
ende des ersten schultags mika zeigt was
er gelernt hat
[Musik]
doris ist erleichtert mika so fröhlich
anzutreffen
[Gelächter]
annika versucht mitzuhalten
in der primarschule in steckborn am
bodensee hatte sie zwei jahre
frühenglisch
[Musik]
[Applaus]
silvia hat beschlossen direkt bei der
hebamme vorbeizufahren
ehemann markus kommt selbstverständlich
mit
[Musik]
irgendwo muss sie sein die frauenklinik
die auswanderer haben glück die hebamme
spricht englisch und nimmt sie spontan
zeit für eine erste sprechstunde das
gegenteil von der massen erwartet haben
mehr oder weniger mit warte und warte
und ja was ist ein freundliches ist
gewohnt mit ausländische prozent wer
sich gut
dann schaut die hebamme wie es dem baby
geht
bisher verlief die schwangerschaft ohne
probleme dennoch sind die boots
vorsichtig silvia hatte bereits drei
fehlgeburten
[Musik]
man hört die herztöne aber da ist noch
etwas anderes
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
also alles in ordnung
[Musik]
bis zur geburt wird die hebamme silvia
regelmäßig untersuchen
[Musik]
es ist natürlich super tag gemeldet und
mir wissen wo du es waren
das geht einfach ein gutes gefühl
[Musik]
so eine karibik die möglichkeit raum
wurde ja ums land hofft dass das treffen
so schnell wie möglich da auch ausleben
kann selig seid ihr fehlt als
geschäftspartner als kollege will meer
hat das zusammen plant aber sie wird
auch das ist jetzt nur der politik
stefano avatar hat mittlerweile sein
erstes geld mit den appartements in der
casa italia gemacht er hat sie tageweise
vermietet sein appartement das seines
kollegen und die wochenend wohnung
seines onkels auch noch gleich mit
das appartement von onkel fernando haben
vier italiener zwei nächte lang
bevölkert
selbst weniger dann checke alles gute
ich nicht gut das muss ich ihnen
verraten
deutschmann alles gut doch nicht
einschritt
nur noch putzen dann ist die wohnung
wieder bereit für die nächsten zahlenden
gäste stephan muss gleich weiter nach
cancún er hat einen termin bei seinem
onkel
[Musik]
onkel fernando wartet schon
fernandos firmen und liebschaften laufen
rund und der neffe hat die geschäfte
schon nach wenigen wochen fest im griff
ganz einfach besser das was ich gesagt
habe und der städtischen stellen die
läuterung weist weist wie die wie hier
die leute dass ich hatte keine ihn sogar
dass der honig muss erschossen wie dc
niveau nicht sogar vermutet habt ja ich
hab's ja und dann werde ich ja okay du
bist sehr schnell nicht mehr bleiben
bleibe ich eine vorliebe worden so
schneider schon gemüse besser übungen
besser so setzt schlaf ist keines der
schweiz arbeitet jemand zugehört
die anwältin hat ihr büro nur einen
stock tiefer auf sie gehört zu fernandos
klar
die anwältin hat neuigkeiten die
aufenthaltsbewilligung von stefano wurde
genehmigt und wird in kürze ausgestellt
stefano hat ein erstes ziel erreicht
ab sofort darf er in mexiko arbeiten
auch ohne seinen onkel
diese aufsicht kann man kaufen
das könnte türkeis alltag werden und vw
steigert sich schon immer auch mit
ausschnitten aus dem doppelhaus ließen
sich leicht vier ferienwohnungen machen
sonys buchholz da glaub schon dass wir
mit der halb halb ebene sind sowieso
mega cool so schöne ferien apartments
kaufen und vermieten eine neue idee von
doris und keyboard
wahnsinn
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ich habe später
ja
[Applaus]
da kommt jeder tourist genau da war
irgendwie mehr sich die wahl zeigt sich
doch heiß nähern sich ihrem traum
schritt für schritt ein haus mit
weitsicht whale watching
die begeisterung hält an schon bald
werden sie den vertrag unterschreiben
[Musik]
in schweden haben bereits erste
sommergäste die ferienwohnungen gebucht
acht wochen hat markus eingeplant dann
sollen zwei ferienhäuser saniert sein
danach will er sich einen job auf dem
bau suchen habe mir gesagt keine zehn
jahren möchte vom hof leben aber so
lange werde ich hier als trainer
schaefer schauen jetzt schlimmsten seine
land wo alles so schön auf holzbasis ist
handwerken und gewisse wertschätzung
noch ist der boden um sicher auf dem sie
sich bewegen und das schon seit einem
jahr
ihr hof am see stuckenbrok muss neu
vermessen werden
bis dahin stehen sie nicht als
eigentümer im grundbuch mittlerweile
zweifeln sie daran dass das in
absehbarer zeit passiert post
verschieben alter sonntag 12 april um 11
uhr vermisst das heißt dass in genau
einer woche ein bis land fertig
vermesser wird das wird in einen tag
macht sie am nächsten tag wird sind
systeme oder übernächsten tag mit ins
grundbuch am tag oder nicht alles
schnell ja wirklich dort parken
die luxair minute 40 stunden dann sage
ich noch mal aber nach wie vor
12 pa keramikfliesen stefano hat den
baumarkt ein schnäppchen gemacht so kann
er den bau der apartments zügig
abschließen
das sind nur zwei besser machen
darum haben es jetzt kauft wenn die
wäsche 60 meter fotobuch zeit ist für
stefano bares geld und playa del carmen
der ideale ort für schnelle
entscheidungen stefanos italienischer
bauleiter ist auf der gleichen
wellenlänge
die neue heimat der auswanderer war bis
vor 50 jahren ein kleines fischerdorf
heute leben hier über 250.000 menschen
der tourismus boomt projekt dass estland
wo man handsets ist fernanda ein haus
mit mindestens acht appartements soll
hier entstehen
finanziert durch wohlhabende käufer die
bei den stephanus eine ferienwohnung
erwerben
ihr plan sie stück vom kuchen von den
abschnitten wenn es sicher möglichkeit
wo sich dort gibt und dann sind wir
trotzdem die möglichkeit ergriffen und
das gleiche programm natürlich von
madonna war natürlich auch ein käufer
aber nicht sicher mit dem nötigen
kleingeld lässt sich das rad immer
schneller drehen muss schauen dass man
bei 349 boden blieb aber norris
anschluss an das klappt nur einmal und
ich bin risikofreudig es ist wahr die
mit sowie somit eigentlich verdammt
nächste woche bei auf und davon
wiedersehen in der schweiz stefan reiter
stellt seine neue freundin vor gästen
uns technologie hat endlich
interessenten gefunden
sylvia poth begrüßt dienstag über den
ersten gast
ihr mann markus der schreiner kämpft mit
schwedischen möbel in südafrika zweifeln
die talker ist doch kein traumhaus und
sie helfen mit beim herbstfest in der
neuen heimat
[Musik]
juli aus
so wie wilders
münster
[Musik]
auf und davon mit der mobiliar
versicherungen und vor